what do you think about that in terms of
if one of your kids to know would be
LGBT short so as a sudden they're still
I think I've only stopped thinking about
it since I've had children really to
understand so it is something I'm
nervous about not because I'm worried
about that being gay but I think it's
more about the fact that I'm worried
about the pressures as you know I'm here
but they're gonna face and how much
harder no life could be so for a parent
party that's that I wore advice is is is
that I wish we live in a world that it
was like you serve that's really normal
you know cool but particular for my
family in the position that we are in
and that's the bit I'm nervous about I
police appointees you know whatever
decision they they make but it doesn't
worry me from her point of view how much
how many barriers you know hateful words
persecution or discrimination that might
come fastball that's the bit that really
troubles me over but that's for all of
us to try and help correct to make sure
we can perhaps the pastor